[Musica]
quante di queste immagini avete visto
negli ultimi anni sicuramente più di una
perché molti di queste foto video tweet
che hanno raccontato alcuni dei più
grandi eventi di attualità degli ultimi
20 anni
eppure molti di questi contenuti non
sono stati realizzati da giornalisti e
professionisti dell'informazione ma da
altri tipi di persone alcuni sono stati
realizzati da semplici passanti che si
trovavano sul luogo di un evento hanno
alzato lo smartphone è scattato una foto
che poi è diventata virare online
altri ancora sono stati prodotti da
organizzazioni con una precisa agenda
politica come nel caso dell isis altri
ancora si sono rivelati del tutto falsi
creati per manipolare l'opinione o
semplicemente per generare traffico
pubblicitario
negli ultimi 20 anni lo scenario
dell'informazione è profondamente
cambiato
non soltanto per noi giornalisti che
ogni giorno ci troviamo a dover trovare
verificare notizie online con modalità
del tutto nuove rispetto a prima ma
anche per voi che prima legate chiamati
il pubblico gli spettatori i lettori gli
utenti e che invece ora siete parte
attiva della macchina dell'informazione
perché ogni foto che scattate e
condividete con il cellulare
ogni video su facebook ogni like o anche
un semplice share con dvd costituisce un
atto più o meno consapevole di
informazione che può cambiare il modo in
cui informate voi stessi ma soprattutto
in cui informate gli altri si tratta di
un passaggio di livello molto importante
che sicuramente ci porterà a costruire
un mondo più aperto e più inclusivo in
cui ciascuno potrà far sentire la
propria voce e raccontare la propria
storia
anche chi prima non ci riusciva ma si
tratta anche di un passaggio di livello
che richiede più spirito critico più
attenzione e più responsabilità
oggi sono qui per condividere con voi
proprio alcuni degli strumenti che noi
giornalisti di solito utilizziamo per
verificare le fonti online lo farò
appunto focalizzandomi nessuna attività
su cui mi sono molto specializzato negli
ultimi anni sia come giornalista
digitale ma anche come ricercatore
ed è proprio la verifica delle fonti
online a verifica delle foto su facebook
twitter la verifica dei video o anche la
verifica dei contenuti che girano sui
forum e sui blog
un'attività che spesso viene chiamata
anche con un termine inglese fact
checking nel 2010 ho vinto una
fellowship l'onestà di oxford presso il
reuters institute for the study of
journalism per sei mesi ho potuto
abbandonare la routine quotidiana del
mio lavoro e concentrarmi su un tema che
mi interessava che era appunto la
verifica delle fonti online la verifica
dei tweet delle foto dei video online
per questi sei mesi durante questi mesi
ho potuto parlarne con giornalisti
brillanti che proveniva da ogni parte
del mondo
ho potuto assistere intelligente
dibattiti sul futuro del giornalismo nel
tempo libero anche imparato a fare
panting nel tamigi
tra le attività previste dalla
fellowship c'erano anche la visita nelle
più grandi redazioni all news londinesi
qui mi vedete la bbc ma siamo andati
anche al guardian reuters da jazira
durante queste visite durante questi
incontri ho potuto dare una risposta
alla domanda con cui era partito
dall'italia durante un grande evento di
attualità e più importante essere i
primi oi più accurati se c'è un
terremoto un'altra emergenza e ci sono
le più a testimonianze come abbiamo
visto più volte sono perlopiù online su
facebook e twitter è più importante di
lanciarle subito ri condividere queste
informazioni oppure fermarsi un attimo e
verificarle tweet force per i file ed
oppure veri pfeiffer street later
questo è diventato anche il titolo del
mio petar finale che è stata una delle
prime ricerche ad occuparsi proprio
della verifica dei social media nelle
grandi organizzazioni che fanno
informazione
le conclusioni purtroppo non hanno del
tutto ottimista perché con l'eccezione
della bbc che è stata l'unica grande
testata a dotarsi di un nucleo interno
di faq checkers di verificatori di
notizie digitali dopo gli attentati
nella metropolitana del 2005 tutte le
altre redazioni continuavano a twittare
a condividere a pubblicare prima ea
verificare dopo i risultati di questo
approccio l'abbiamo visto bene negli
anni a seguire
quando testate piccole e grandi italiane
e straniere hanno rilanciato notizie che
non ci sono mai stati
qui vedete un tweet falso della bbc che
annuncia la morte della regina
elisabetta che invece ancora vive e
vegeta ci hanno raccontato grosse
emergenze grossi terremoti con le
immagini sbagliate e video sbagliati
il v il caso più emblematico forse
questo tweet del 2013 che annuncia due
esplosioni alla casa bianca e obama che
è rimasto ferito
prima ancora che arrivasse una conferma
della casa bianca
il tweet fa il giro del mondo wall
street crolla con dow jones che perde
130 punti in pochissimi secondi
vedete notizie false effetti reali
questa storia sarebbe ripetuta molto di
più
ancora negli anni a venire quando ho
lasciato oxford per tornare in italia e
tornare a fare appunto il mio lavoro di
giornalista digitale ancora non avevo
capito la portata di questo fenomeno
pensavo che fosse qualcosa che
riguardasse perlopiù noi giornalisti e
il mondo dell'informazione
pensavo quindi che bastasse fare più
formazione introdurre strumenti di
verifica digitale nelle redazioni in
realtà proprio tra il 2010 e il 2011 una
serie di fenomeni hanno fatto emergere
un altro fenomeno ancora più grande è
ancora imprevisto sono arrivati
cellulari low cost smartphone low cost è
arrivata la rete mobile davvero veloce
soprattutto facebook in italia ha
contribuito a portare milioni di nuovi
utenti online persone che non avevano
mai acceso un computer mai aperto un
browser
improvvisamente si trovavano in un nuovo
mondo dove avevano accesso a decine
centinaia migliaia di fonti spesso
questo passaggio è avvenuto dalla
televisione a internet a facebook senza
che ci fosse una vera e propria alfabeti
alfabetizzazione digitale senza che ci
fosse una formazione su quali fossero le
differenze tra una fonte televisiva e
delle fonti online
molte di queste persone così non sanno
che tra queste decine centinaia migliaia
di fonti online e sono anche alcune che
diffonde notizie false che alcune di
queste fonti guadagnano anche 10 mila
dollari al mese
diffondendo queste notizie che la
manipolazione politica oggi si serve
anche di questi strumenti per cambiare
le nostre opinioni ed è stato così che
siamo trovati davanti a bacheche con
persone che conosciamo che stimiamo
spesso anche con un alto livello di
istruzione che condividevano
se di scie chimiche vaccini letali
dichiarazioni di politici che non sono
mai state morti che non ci sono mai
stati
condividi prima verifica dopo il
fenomeno che avevo rilevato ad oxford
nel mondo giornalistico
ora si è espanso ed era esploso sera
democratizzato con conseguenze che
abbiamo visto benissimo durante le
ultime elezioni statunitensi 2016 quando
le notizie provenienti da fonti false
sono state più condivisa di quelle
provenienti da fonti mainstream come new
york times il washington post la storia
si è ripetuta in italia durante l'ultimo
referendum costituzionale quando la
notizia più condiviso in assoluto è una
notizia proveniente da un sito
piccolissimo con pochissimi lettori e
che pure è stato in grado di attirare
più di 235 mila con divisioni sulla
notizia che parlava di un fatto
totalmente falso come avete potuto
sentire immagino negli ultimi mesi
tutti stanno a parlare adesso di fake
news o struth diventata la parola
dell'anno post verità è scattato anche
un po di scaricabarile tutti a dire
colpa di google e facebook che
sicuramente hanno le loro responsabilità
e dovrebbero fare di più per limitare la
diffusione delle notizie false online
c'è qualche politico maldestro che
addirittura proposto di introdurre leggi
più severe per punire chi diffonde
informazioni false online senza porsi
però più di tanto i problemi della
libertà dell'espressione
dell'informazione che forse viene prima
io in realtà credo che è arrivato il
momento che tutti quanti noi ci
prendiamo le nostre responsabilità
e quando dico noi non intendo soltanto
noi giornalisti che sicuramente dobbiamo
fare di più per diffondere notizie
verificate ma intendo chiunque abbia uno
smartphone
chiunque si informi online ed appunto
accesso una varietà di fonti a cui prima
non aveva accesso
proprio per questo motivo l'anno scorso
insieme un gruppo di colleghi di amici
ho fondato un'associazione che si chiama
fact checkers il cui obiettivo è portare
la cultura delle fonti l'approccio
critico all'informazione nei contesti
educativi quindi nelle scuole con i
docenti e gli alunni ma anche nelle
famiglie con i genitori ei figli
in realtà la scuola e le famiglie sono
soltanto il nostro primo obiettivo
la nostra ambizione più grande
ed è arrivare a chiunque abbiano
smartphone in tasca a ciascuno di voi
quindi suppongo per farli diventare dei
fac checkers dei verificatori delle
notizie
lo vogliamo fare con formati e il più
possibile innovative e coinvolgenti come
questa guida galattica per esploratori
di notizie che senza demonizzare le faq
news senza spaventarci più di tanto ci
offre 10 semplici consigli 10 trucchi
per a porci con maniera in maniera più
critica con l'informazione online
l'abbiamo usata di recente durante la
prima giornata mondiale del fact
checking lo scorso 2 aprile a sky
academy
quando abbiamo formato i nostri primi
fax cento faq checkers 100 ragazzi tra i
15 e 18 anni che adesso si approccia
alle informazioni in maniera un po più
critica condivido con voi anche alcuni
di questi strumenti ad esempio quanti di
voi conoscono questo simbolo sono sicuro
che ogni giorno lo incontrate decine di
volte di volte sulle vostre bacheche
facebook e twitter
anche perché vuol dire appunto che vi
trovate di fronte un profilo verificato
cioè la persona che trovate che sta
scrivendo diffondendo un contenuto è
autentica e stata verificata
eppure nonostante sia così diffuso
oramai lo usano molti politici molte
personalità famose ma anche i grossi
brand organizzazioni di ogni tipo
secondo uno studio di stanford solo uno
studente su quattro sari conosce lo sa
cosa vuol dire i risultati di questa
ignoranza che vedete davvero minima
possono essere mostruosi un po di anni
fa questo post su facebook con finito
con la volkswagen che diceva di voler
regalare auto che non potevano essere
messe più sul mercato ha ottenuto decine
centinaia di migliaia di like persone
che hanno messo like senza appunto
chiedersi minimamente se quell'account
era verificato meno se avesse o meno la
spunta blu
a proposito di like facili sei utenti di
noi su dieci mette like fa con dvd senza
nemmeno leggere quello che sta
condividendo i risultati anche in questo
caso possono essere disastrosi come nel
caso di questa notizia condivisa da
centinaia di italiani che annuncia
l'arrivo della banconota da 1.000 euro
solo per ricchi naturale
che in realtà è stata pubblicata dal
fatto quotidiano e non dal fatto
quotidiano
anche qui una conoscenza davvero piccola
che però trae in inganno siti di questo
tipo oramai ne esistono a bizzeffe cioè
il matto quotidiano il fatto né
quotidiano repubblica con l'abi il
corriere della sera del mattino della
notte della pera l'osservatore politico
e panorana che la var variante anfibia
del noto magazine attenti poi anche le
immagini spesso le immagini sono
photoshoppate ma ancora più spesso sono
immagini autentiche immagini vere che
vengono poste fuori con un contesto ad
esempio questa immagine è stata
circolato molto online a cantà notizie
che annunciavano l'invasione dal nord
africa di di molti immigrati
in realtà anche fa basta fare una cosa
che ha un nome un po difficile brutto
che si ricerca inversa delle immagini ma
che è molto semplice basta fare clic col
tasto destro del mouse sull'immagine si
va su google immagini dove all'istante
in pochissimi secondi si visualizza
l'origine di questa immagine che appunto
si riferiva al 1991 quando dell'albania
arrivano tantissimi albanesi che stavano
fuggendo dal loro paese
bene non è il tempo di far vedere questi
e gli altri processi o strumenti che
abbiamo messi nella nostra guida che
potete trovare qui a questo indirizzo
potete trovare anche un decalogo
dell'esploratore digitale 10 simboli
semplici consigli per approcciarsi in
maniera più critica di informazione on
line
troverete anche un quiz per mettere alla
prova le vostre abilità le vostre
capacità di fax checkers perché una cosa
oramai accerta è finita l'età
dell'innocenza del pri ma condivido e
poi verifico se la notizia sono
informazioni e vero falsa ed è iniziata
l'età della responsabilità cioè tempo
che tutti quanti noi giornalisti ma
soprattutto voi chiunque abbia un
cellulare si informa online si fermi un
attimo a riflettere a pensare prima di
condividere postare può fruttare
qualcosa e tempo cioè che diventiamo
tutti dei fax hackers
grazie mille
[Applauso]